Have a Holly Jolly Christmas it's the
best time of the
[Music]
year I wish I knew more
traditional Christmas songs I always
know the first line or two but I don't
know enough of it to kind of do it you
know and I wish I knew more I have the
first have
a jolly Christmas is the best time of
the year and then I don't know
um well it's the final episode of the
Year folks and we uh appreciate you
being with us
um I don't know if this is a Christmas
story to be honest with you is it ever
is it ever on this show is it ever a fun
holiday story is it ever a nice story we
got to do that one day just nice
but it's as I've said before the nice
stories are almost more terrifying
because it's like a guy who walked to
work every day for 70 years and now has
diabetes and one leg and no health
insurance uh everybody at the plant that
he works at got together and bought him
a car that's like the N that's like the
nice
version of the story like there is no
just really not you
know so this is a story about a
marauding group of white Suburban
teenagers in uh Arizona going around and
killing
people well that's not
nice and apparently they're well connect
we cannot show any of this by the way so
don't I mean I don't think we can show
any of this this is all violent yeah you
have to be very careful here we're under
a
microscope we got an election coming up
and there going to get real tight on the
Independent Media of which I am one one
of the most powerful members of The
Independent Media in the world
me and because of that they're going to
be uh very difficult to deal with these
sensors
MH so if there's a way to show any of
this we have to do it very blurry or
small yep yeah all right I'm just
putting that out there because the kids
now are filming
their uh beatings
their let's let's start at the
beginning let's start at the beginning
it's a Christmas
story let's start at the beginning there
is a state called
Arizona Arizona
is
fine outside of Scottdale and Paradise
Valley where I have several friends and
they maintain
beautiful uh Spanish style desert
residences is some Modern and many of
them have left the high tax state of
California and have
escaped to well not the greener pastures
but the brown uh pastures of and I like
a desert Mansion I don't hate it I spent
quarantine in Palm Springs I have no
hatred uh for the you know the the
desert thing it's not for me per say but
I outside of uh
Scottdale and Paradise Valley don't know
anyone in Arizona I don't know how it
works I don't know how it works I know
only Scottdale I know only Paradise
Valley and that's all I want to know
because when you get out of those places
you're in some type of Hell really it's
like 115 degrees every day they have
these fake lakes that they diee this
aquamarine color and all these people
get in these little Swan Boats and it's
hellish out there and I'm not saying
it's the it's the surface of Mars is how
they live these
people
now there's a town called Gilbert
Arizona I've never been to this place I
will never be to this place unless
something go horribly wrong in my life
um lot of Mormons this ties in with the
LDS church the Mormons are involved I
got very big into this I'm not usually
into True Crime I really am not because
it's it's usually some woman who gets
kidnapped and you're like oh boy you
know what I mean and it's a very woman
thing True Crime it's a because women
fantasize about men who love them enough
to kidnap them and put them in a trunk
but I've never you know I so I don't
really I have not been a um a
connoisseur of the genre of podcasting
which is the biggest in the world right
true crime and I just basically uh pay
attention to the new news and I read
news from all over the country and all
over the world so I bring things to you
before they happen who knew Megan Marco
was a [__] I did years ago I knew it was
a joke when I was saying people were
celebrating it I was going wait Watch
What Happens
here I'm following this news out of
Gilbert Arizona where this gang of uh
children this marauding group of
white privileged and I mean you know
Arizona privilege they have uh these big
houses that look like Olive Gardens or
Macaroni Grills you know I mean the kid
who's accused of doing this I think his
parents own an orange theory gym so you
call the reddits what do you think asse
me for that they don't know you know
what kind of lawyers I have you know
what kind of lawyers I have Beverly
Hills attorneys I have New York City
attorneys buddy what are you
nuts so I'm not saying anybody's name by
the way because I'm not doing
that my point is that on the reddits
they talk about this family like they're
the the kennedies they own a gym they
own a martial arts gym but this is
Arizona everyone there a lot of them
they're all so desperate they live in
litter boxes in hell and and it's sand
traps in hell they live in so the family
that owns the kickboxing gym is like the
Bush family to these people who live in
hell no offense am I offending anyone
you live in hell and have nothing so to
anyone that has anything these people
are impressed these houses are all made
of the finishes that people that I know
we use in like the outdoor fireplace and
then these people put it on the whole
house my I'm going to get really
distracted here and this whole thing is
going to be about masonry and that's not
what I want it to be about my my my
first of all none of this is going in
anyone who lives in Scottdale who I've
several friends of Scott still in
Paradise
Valley the great Phoenician lot of lot
of respect a lot of people
there what am I even saying there's a
group of kids killing people in the
street I
think they're called the Gilbert goons
they're a small group of people and they
run around and they attack brutally
attack kids they bash their heads in and
and uh and uh their teeth are flying
everywhere and they they're doing it in
an In-N-Out parking lot and everything
and they a lot of these kids are rich by
the standards of
Arizona by the standards of
Arizona by the standards of Gilbert
Arizona not Scott you know so they're
connected connected but then there's the
Mormons who involved now I don't know
much about the Mormons I really don't I
don't know anything about the Mormons
other than again please don't be mad at
me it's a very stupid religion as the
world religions go it's very very dumb
the premise of Mormonism is that God
dictat ated the real deal to a
illiterate guy who is also a drunk named
Joseph Smith and then that's the whole
point here whatever you're and now by
the way if it helps you live a good life
hey if it helps you live a good life if
it helps you not kill and fornicate and
whatever if it is what you need do it
that's the way I feel about everything
now as I get older it's what you need as
long as what you need doesn't uh uh make
me like um you know infringe on my right
to be a person that doesn't agree with
your thing that's why I'm a little
skeptical of the in hordes of uh uh
people coming over from uh the uh Middle
Eastern countries because they seem
serious about the religion very serious
um so the Mormon thing my cousin's
husband is a excommunicated from
Mormonism because he as any reasonably
intelligent 17-year-old he sat down when
they went this is a [__] rarded this
is not it now Mormons I guess are kind
of gangsters I didn't know this but
they're kind of gangsters the Marriott
family they own all the hotels in all of
the world they're a big Mormon F I
didn't know anything about this
latterday Saints I just knew Mitt Romney
was a Mormon and again don't be offended
if you're a Mormon and you like this
show good for you but it just it seems
silly objectively it seems like an
objectively silly religion a lot of
these religions are just created to
siphon money from people control them
whatever we all know this whatever now
now the Mormons don't talk to the cops
they don't they uh they protect their
own it's insular this is what I've
learned on Reddit threads and reading
about the more I don't know these things
people tell me my cousin's husband tells
me about these things so in this town
where people are apparently incredibly
privileged because they own uh the Poke
Ball spot their kids are like uh a
athletes
and they're doing very well and they're
and they're just going around this
Valley what is it called this place
Gilbert no but the East Valley oh East
Valley what is who are so they're going
around this Valley the East Valley and
they're attacking kids randomly and the
whole and everybody in the community is
going stop trying stop killing my
children in the community now and they
just ran that article that Gilbert
Arizona one of the best places to live
yeah and these kids are going around
beating people up and the and the and
the cops are doing nothing the cops are
like not arresting these Mormon rich
kids this also happened in Gilbert
Arizona years ago was a gang called the
devil dog some white supremacist gang
supposedly probably was that maybe
worked with Sammy the bul gravano
selling ecstasy I think unless I'm
mixing that up but I'm not it's the
Devil Dogs they were a gang in Gilbert
and I think they were working with
gravano because gravano moved to Arizona
he was selling accy whatever um
tell there's a something weird in the
town and the town has the big Temple the
LDS temple right very
interesting um so they kind of protect
their own so these kids are running
around attacking people and nothing is
happening nobody's getting arrested
nobody's and and you know they're white
and they have money what people in
Gilbert Arizona consider
money no
offense just not it's not one hide Ark
you don't know what it is Google it
piggy these kids are running around
they're all psychotic they're
sociopaths they think their gangsters
are acting out rap songs they have a rap
song that I heard which is not good
they're using drugs they got guns in the
videos the brass knuckles they have the
gun out in the they're in the you know
the Macaroni Grill style mansion in
Arizona with the gun out I'm a thug I'm
17 I'm a Mormon Thug in in Arizona
desert Macaroni Grill house it's crazy
and it's a fascinating story you can
show that right yeah the kids with the
guns and they're in the house you know
so I'm this is interesting to me because
the cops are doing nothing and I know
people there I know like people there I
know everyone thinks it's Carrie Lake
it's not Carrie Lake you know it's not
but I know other people but I know
people in the
state and they're like they're like this
is super weird that none of these kids
have been arrested because here's the
deal they kill a kid this is what I've
left out there's a Halloween party and
this kid uh Preston Lord this young kid
sadly gets murdered he's attacked they
stomp his head out on the ground I mean
this is really crazy stuff for the
nicest uh town to live in in America
right and what's not to like 110 degrees
fake Lakes
tarantulas you know what I mean what
what what couldn't what's not to like
dust storms scorpions snakes it's
lovely now marauding groups of teenage
Mormons trying to kill you and they
trying to kill your kids and the cops
doing nothing what is not to like
here so they kill this kid and nothing
is done they don't do anything the cops
don't do anything supposedly the cops
are in cahoots with the parents who are
in cahoots with the school this prep
school that these kids go to I can't
really say the names of these things
because everybody's litigious
MH so I'm not going to say that right am
I wrong you tell me we shouldn't say the
names I'm not g to say the names a kid
can I say the name of the school you can
say the name of the school we could
bleep it out if we find out later we
shouldn't have
it I don't know what that but what is
that even mean the episode comes out
tomorrow yeah it's a school in Gilbert
Arizona where a lot of rich kids go yeah
let's keep it at that keep it f keep it
at that yeah yeah I'm not trying to get
sued mhm what if this is a Jesse Smet
thing where we find out these kids
didn't do it they probably did it I
think they did it I think they did it
yeah but you got to be careful now
because you know so they kill this kid
and the cops do nothing really and the
now the town has gone nuts they're
leaving their houses these tiny little
Olive G Gardens wedged into the sand
dirt where they
live and then some of the people even
from the bigger Olive Garden Macaroni
Grill style homes and they're leaving
these homes they're leaving their
recliners they're leaving their uh
desert pools their turquoise desert
pools they're walking outside onto their
uh fluorescent lit
streets in the middle of the Iraq where
they live and they're
walking to the police station they're
going do something you you Mormons
MH this is what's happening in AR does
anyone care this is the
news this is the news now what's
happening there's people in Arizona who
just want Justice for the kid whose head
was stomped out by these crazy
kids and and everyone knows who they are
like everybody on the reddits and all
these things are going no it's these
kids they're the ones who've done it
and play this this is this is uh this is
the mother or the
aunt she's
speaking and she's speaking of this
Memorial this is very sad yeah this is
the vigil uh
Thursday when we got the call that
Preston had been jumped my husband as
the protector of the family assumed the
role of navigating traffic signals to
get us to the hospital as quickly and
safely as
possible as the nurse I assumed the role
of evaluating medical scenarios of what
his condition would look like at the
trauma center when we
arrived bruises maybe a black eye or
some broken bones never could I have
imagined the scene that we would walk
into that
night I was the first one to get to the
hospital I checked in and I said I'm
Preston Lord's aunt and he was just
brought in as a
trauma the girl's eyes immediately
dropped avoiding I contact with me and
said please come with
me she buzzed me into a small room
sterile and alone four White Walls one
tan couch a single sage green chair one
medical supply box of
cleanups as the averting eyes closed the
door to this Hospital cell the only word
she could give me were the doctor and
social work will be in soon yes okay
listen this is very tragic uh the this
this Tri these kids got to go to jail
they have to go to jail but the cops
have done nothing their SWAT team serves
some uh warrants all of this stuff's on
Snapchat I mean this is a it's a human
tragedy and the kids who did it are
monsters right these are they've been
doing it they've been so then you think
about how do you raise a
monster this is this is a good question
this is something to think about in the
BBS but it
happens it actually happens when kids
have nothing to lose they feel like they
have nothing to lose whether they are
from the projects and they feel like
they they see all their friends get
killed in front of them and the value on
on human life is very low because they
are thrust into a world um where things
are insane from a young
age uh you know you you you have people
that
become sociopaths because they you know
in order to just function you have to
shut off the part of yourself that has
any feelings now this also happens in
the suburbs where people are quite
comfortable and you have kids that are
just genuinely going out randomly
attacking kids doing serious damage to
them and killing one of them and then
you have their parents swooping in and
going we're going to protect you and
we're going to try to we're going to
help you get away with
murder which
is never had a relationship to my
parents like that but I guess a lot of
people
do I like my parents I love my parents
they're good people but they I don't
they never would have tried to uh Shield
me from the consequences had I murdered
somebody and they have recommended
finally the Gilbert PD's recommended
charges to a bunch of these kids but it
says juveniles and adults that that
could mean that some of the kids are 18
but that could also mean that they will
charge some of the parents
with trying to
obstruct and protect these kids and it's
an ex-girlfriend it's always the one who
gets you she's coming out and and
telling people what went
down this kid was 16 when he died when
your kid dies it really ruins your whole
life as an adult as a parent you can
never really come back from
that you can live a life you can live a
good life but you can never come
back fully from losing a child this is
it doesn't happen so the idea that the
kids who did it would get off or go
free is
crazy crazy enough that even the people
of
Arizona were motivated to take to the
streets and stop these rich by Arizona
standards parents from
protecting their children
and trying
to you know pressure the cops or maybe
they're working with the cop maybe one
of these kids parents is a cop we don't
know we don't know about
that but it's got to be mading to see
nothing
done and people are going to go well
they're rich white kids this happens
often well you know I I'm I'm sure that
it happens more often than than when
they are black we know that we get it
but there should be uh some justice here
for this child that was murdered and
that's this case that I've been
following these Gilbert goons it's a
squad of marauding Mormons maybe I don't
know maybe it's not and by the way if it
comes out that they're not Mormons then
hey egg on my face
apologies everything being written about
this
suggests that they are
Mormons and that they kind of protect
their own out there
in Arizona I didn't even know they were
there I thought it was
Utah but apparently there's a big
presence
in Gilbert Arizona and good for the
citizens the citizens are going the
police are corrupt they're incompetent
best case they're incompetent but
they're probably corrupt and they're not
doing anything
so I think when they blow this open when
it becomes national news and I'm talking
about it before it's national news M um
it'll become like a very very big deal
and that a lot of maybe Heads Will Roll
with the cops or anything like that I
don't know I don't know I don't
know in another Spate of happy news of
Florida teen kills his sister over
Christmas
presents I gotta be honest with you my I
was at a few Christmases this year my
fathers my cousins I am telling you
right
now I am I feel
like we are getting kids too many
presents in the
country I think this is what makes the
Gilbert goons goons we give them too
much I I my my cousin told her mother
get only one gift her
child my aunt and I think that's good
because kids are getting way too
much way too
much abrielle Baldwin 23 the mother of a
six-year-old and an 11mon year old an
11mon old 11mon year old and an
11-month-old was fatally shot by her
14-year-old brother on Christmas Eve
where is this Florida yep it's another
paradise isn't it a 14-year-old Florida
teen fatally shot his sister in an
argument over Christmas
gifts the argument started when the
brothers ages 14 and 15 were out
shopping on Christmas Eve Sunday with
their mother and sister and got into a
spat over who was receiving more
Christmas
gifts after shopping the boys their
mother their 23-year-old sister and the
two young children went to their
grandmother's home in Largo where the
argument can can you imagine the
argument
continued so I guess they're at like a
mall or something mhm they start
fighting about who's getting more
gifts the 23-year-old sister should be I
know she's got two kids but still she
shouldn't be getting any gifts you're an
adult the gift cut off has got to happen
at 18 a few things for college that's
it that's when the 14-year-old brother
stood in the doorway he took out his 40
caliber semi-automatic hand handgun he
pointed it at his brother and told him
he was going to shoot him in the
head the 14-year-old tried to get his
15-year-old brother to fight and an
uncle ended up separating them and
moving the 14-year-old outside into the
driveway area that's where he found
abrielle carrying her 11-month-old baby
in a carrier she told him you all need
to leave that stuff alone why are you
trying to start it it's Christmas the
14-year-old argued with her calling her
derogatory terms and shot her in the CH
as she was holding her infant in the
carrier she fell and the baby fell but
the baby was
unharmed the 15-year-old brother then
came outside took out a 45 caliber
semi-automatic handgun exclaimed you
shot my [__] sister and then
shot the 14-year-old one time in the
stomach the sheriff said there was an 8C
gap between the time the 14-year-old
shot abrielle and before he himself was
shot at the time he was shot he was no
longer in possession of his gun the
15-year-old then ran through his gun in
a nearby yard and is it who got them all
the guns for
Christmas is that that might be a
problem maybe it wasn't a good idea last
Christmas everybody get a gun everyone
got a 40 cal for Christmas in this
family abrielle was taken to a hospital
died of her
wounds she was just a woman going about
life doing her thing with her two kids
now you got two kids and their mom's
dead this is the
quote 14-year-old is charged with
first-degree
murder child abuse and being a
delinquent in possession of a firearm
the kids this is the problem remember
when you know there was this idea that
like the children are the future and the
children are going to the children are a
real big
problem in this
country um
and I think yeah well these kids carried
guns all the
time they're out in the middle of the
night doing car burglaries the kid the
the the you know how many of these
homicides are young people
tons young people in this country are a
threat to
everyone when I see a young person I'm
on edge I'm not even kidding when I see
a young person now I'm 38 if I am in a
mall restaurant like a high-end Mall
restaurant uh fig and olive if you will
if I'm in the Houston Galleria at fig
and
olive and I see a young person I'm
immediately on edge I'm immediately on
edge I expect to be shot or to be
lectured about the names they want to be
called young people now are uh sick
we've made them
sick and they're they they have no like
this Gilbert thing that the Snapchats
are sending are like yeah hit a Kitt's
dead
now they're unfeeling uncaring Monsters
the whole lot of them by the way I'm
sure there are some good ones but the
vast majority of young people now
are they're
unstable they're unstable they have no
solid footing of which to uh proceed to
create a life and it's terrifying being
a is someone who sees and reads all this
[__] about uh young people and how sick
they
are you know I'm much more wary of young
people than I am older people young
people don't they don't see violence as
any something that's real I don't know
what it is life has no value to them
they don't seem to care about it they Li
like and and I I'm not saying that these
qualities aren't present in older people
but it's incredibly terrifying when you
see these qualities emerge in a younger
person a 14 15 16y old who doesn't
attach put any value on human
life and you see them in the malls you
see them out
there with the dead eyes they have dead
eyes the
young young people have dead I mean God
what's what is what have we done to them
why are they like this have you ever and
I'm telling you I'm not wrong go to a
diner go to a restaurant go to a gastro
pub go anywhere you see a large family
the one who's 14 there's something with
their
eyes something's
up this is we're getting the evidence
and by the way remember we had no
evidence we're like we don't know what
it's we just give two-year-olds MacBook
we don't know what Happ we give them
iPads we don't know what happens well
here's what happens they become the
Goons
when when you raise children you
Outsource the raising of your children
to algorithms they've become monsters
truly I see them you see them they're
out you see them they just they have
dead
eyes go and speak to a teenager at a
holiday party they have dead eyes and
it's
terrifying and I know you're G to I'm I
going to get all these mess not all of
them well a lot of them do a lot of them
do a lot of them
do I think we have more than enough
evidence now that whatever we're doing
to them is not
ideal across the
board it's kind of it's kind of you know
disturbing I don't have children myself
obviously and I but I know people that
do and they're trying to do the right
thing but like you know I also
know that a lot of these kids they just
they're it's they're fully being raised
on Tik Tok they're fully being raised by
algorithms they're just the what's cool
to these kids they're
nihilists you know they they've grown up
in this environment where there's
nothing is real we at least saw the
institutions like the Catholic church
and the government we at least saw them
fall from a pedestal but at least there
was that
pedestal and then when we started to get
older we started to see the cracks and
the foundation these kids have never had
any authority figure they've ever
respected their life is chaos pure chaos
from the moment they're cognizant of
anything their lives are pure
chaos
chaos this is not good
apparently this is very very bad way to
live when you're a child when you're
when you're
there uh trying to figure out how to
orient yourself in the world world and
Everywhere You Look is is is something
that
is is is the ruins of something
everybody hates each other no one agrees
on what reality is and the only the only
thing that's cool is
drugs violence killing
people having money having
things it's crazy there's no value
system you could plug any of that into
it's nuts it's completely
nuts I'm I'm
hopeful that we can figure out a
way to
like maybe maybe the schools should be
jails to be
honest maybe we should kind of
identify these kids as like maybe we
should kind of treat them like like
criminals they're a
problem the children are a
problem it it's not they're not the
future that's that's not happening that
Canard is not happen the children are
not the future the children are a threat
to the common
good they are a threat to society
children teenagers spe they are a threat
to the fabric of our society and they
need to be dealt with dealt
with dealt
with what was this is this a great idea
that none of them work is it a good idea
that no children work I'm just serious
now is it a good idea that not one child
in this country has a [__] job
anymore nobody works at the movie
theater nobody takes the tickets for the
for the uh the
fair kids used to work now they don't
work anymore any more they sit around in
mansions doing fent andol and waving
guns around on Tik Tock they need to
work all we heard from the Communist to
rais my generation is how unfair it was
in the workhouses in England because uh
Oliver wanted uh can I have more GRL and
they wouldn't give him more GRL or
whatever now now everyone has gr and
everyone's ,000 pounds so we've
overcorrected now no kids are in the
workhouses none of them are working at
all
these lazy fox have GRL for days they
can press a button on their phone and
someone comes in and gives them a
burrito and a gun so they're all in
their Arizona uh Olive Garden style
mansions in a backyard in a swimming
pool doing fent and all and looking for
hunting for people to kill because none
of them have job I had jobs when I was a
kid I had jobs I worked I worked with my
mother who was an overweight lifeguard
she was a swim coach and and the little
children she taught how to swim loved
her they cling to her like a flotation
device and and and she brought me into
that my father got me a job working for
some drunk who owned a restaurant and he
wouldn't serve coffee because he wanted
to be unique and everybody hated him I
was the bus boy in that restaurant for a
few months but I kept [__] it up and
they got rid of me but the point is I
always worked you should get your
working papers at 14 or 15 and you
should have a [__]
job this idea that children should not
work is the worst idea all of this
anti-work [__] is being pushed by people
who want to tear apart the entire fabric
of our
society don't work man it's so cool you
shouldn't work just [__] hang out why
you got to go into the office you don't
got to work nobody was the work any this
whole thing all of these kids in the
suburbs now they don't have bosses they
have no responsibility their parents
don't care about them because they're
doing Taio or whatever these parents are
doing they're managing the martial arts
whatever these [__] people own they
don't care about their kid they don't
care they're checked out they're trying
to make money by Arizona standards
they're trying to make money they don't
have time to sit down with the kid and
go hey are you killing people look at me
you dead eyed little freak will you look
at me you dead eyed little monster look
at me are you killing people in the
In-N-Out parking lot while I'm out
training these fat
Arizona [__] Housewives and widows so
they can go out and snag a second
husband so they can get a house on a
fake turquoise Lake and this dump are
you killing people while I'm doing that
look at me you freak they don't have the
time these parents don't have the time
they're trying to climb the ladder of
nothing in Arizona it happens in New
York City too these big hedge front
people their kids going in at a re I
have a friend this guy he's a companion
for these like severely autistic
children who were literally abandoned
like FAL cats in Central Park by their
parents because they wanted to go to
shad and go skiing and these fural cat
children literally autistic on a level
it's great you say hello to them they
go and my friend has to walk them around
they're addicted to the internet they
jerk off so much their penis falls off
these kids have gone nuts and they
they've been abandoned and their parents
are out you know in Aspen or in Palm
Beach and they're trying to climb these
corporate ladders and their children are
abandoned just to fend for themselves
and some of them develop you know the
severe uh social anxiety disorders or
whatever and then my friend much like a
sober companion he has to walk them
around and tell them about his horrible
life so that they feel better I guess I
don't know but the point
is what what I'm saying here and what
I'm saying is this this movement where
we took children out of factories is not
good if a child had a factory job if a
child could leave school and go to a
factory and put the time in they would
be better off if a child had if we could
have a manufacturing base in this
country with
children teenagers that had to work and
we cut the cut this [__] out with the
college now enough with that that does
nothing for anyone the biggest losers I
know are in $200,000 worth of student
loan debt they got nothing going going
on children have to work they need to
work at the movie theater I know it's
okay well nobody goes to the movie
theater Tim how do they work at the
movie theater I don't know they work at
The Vape Shop wherever they got to
[__] work they shouldn't have all
this time they shouldn't have all this
time to murder the kids have too much
time to kill literally and the parents
don't care the parents don't care
they're uninterested they're trying to
get another Tesla they're uninterested
in what the kids are doing they're not
sitting down with the kids and asking
them are you killing anyone excuse me
and all these kids names are like jayen
and brillin and all these fake [__]
crazy names that they're mothers gave
them it's like give them real names God
forbid out of the Bible and make them
work in a factory or something that's a
good it's a good happy medium North
Korea North Korea would do this North
Korea is trying to become a tourist
destination uh they're also ramping up
uh uh attack they're ramping up their
military they're trying to get ready for
a war with uh Yours Truly the United
States so now North Korea has welcomed
tourists in the past however uh it is
unlikely that any of those tourists will
be American
bummer get some North Korean restaurants
up get some North Korean restaurants
let's see what they're doing here's the
thing with North Korea it's it's very
it's kind of
Bleak it's Bleak it's not great if you
if you want to
really
yeah see that one The Grand Theater
restaurant let's see
that let's see that let's take a look at
those photos there just
one yeah see that here's the thing North
Korea I know you've put by the way
probably better than Gilbert Arizona but
I know that you've put a lot of work
into the missiles and you've put a lot
of work into you know the end of the
world but you got to put a little more
work I don't hate the orange
napkin by the way I don't I do not hate
the orange napkin I don't hate the
orange napkin and I don't hate the
attempt at
Greenery but it needs to be a little
focused I you know it
seems I don't know it's a it's a little
uh empty it feels a little uh but I like
that it's
uncluttered see the good version of this
would be you say it's uncluttered space
the bad version of it would be you know
it's kind of creepy and I think that's
what North Korea a lot of North Korea's
public spaces are kind of Haunting and
creepy and a lot of their restaurants
are uh unappealing to people because of
that so if you want tourists you have to
kind of get you have to have
fun what are the biggest tourist
destinations in America Disney World get
them up get the biggest tourists I'm
going to guess I'm going to say Disney
world's number one I say Las Vegas is in
the top five I say New York City is
maybe number two what are the biggest
tourist destinations in the United
States of America because then we can
really let North Korea know how to do
it Time Square is number one it's uh
Central Park is number two Las Vegas is
number
three Union state by the way this is I
don't know that this is true because
Disney World's got to be number one yeah
so this is not
true Disney World's number seven on
their list Disney World's number seven
well maybe Disney's lost because they're
turning all the kids trans isn't that
what's going on yeah yeah here's what I
mean in North Korea North Korea needs to
figure out they don't have Harry Potter
World they don't have Disney
World what has North Korea got they have
like a sub Museum from like a a boat
they captured in the ' 50s uh what kind
of boat like a submarine no it's like an
American uh they captured an American
submarine and then they made it into a
museum
yes yeah I'll tell you right now it's I
just remember seeing it on yeah internet
well I don't know how many people that's
getting over there the USS Play Blow yes
Play Blow yeah yeah here there you
go yeah I mean I don't that doesn't seem
that
exciting right yeah I don't no it we
need we need more than
this what we do really well as a country
is simulate fun we're really good at it
that's why we
like our adult population likes theme
parks and they love cruises
because if you're left to have fun on
your own you have to appreciate nature
or history or Cuisine you know things
that most people in this country don't
really appreciate and cannot afford so
what's left for the rest of those people
is a simulated good time fun that is
given to you it's an all-inclusive
resort here's the beach here's the booze
here's the thing we don't we don't you
are not trusted to plan any of your own
activities the activities are here for
you you know here's what you got so
North Korea needs to figure out how to
make an adult theme park that is
attractive to people from all over the
world and it might be submarine land
like you could figure out a way to have
a big because they're they're I'm not
saying don't like their whole military
dictatorship Vibe lean into it yeah lean
in because it's kind of cool if I know
that I can visit North Korea but not be
captured and killed or my brain
scrambled like out of warba I'm a freak
I want to go if you want to be the like
military dictatorship that allows people
in MH I'm with it I'm with it it's not
going to be Harry Potter world it's not
going to be what we do but if you're
gonna be like a stark
cold but you know but we're there to
appreciate and respect
power you know like it would be a fun
thing if I was a tourist in North Korea
and there was a like maybe a big outside
balcony in a restaurants in an outside
balcony and the government of North
Korea shows us that they could turn the
lights on and off in the the town next
door M I'll go to see that you know and
they turn the lights off and you hear
everyone go and then they turn it back
on if if it's fun like that I'll be into
it if it's fun like that it's got but
it's you got to lean into the fact that
you are a
creepy fascist place you can't run away
from that it can't all be you know fun
and sunshine and song If I visiting
North Korea I want the grit I want that
like New York City lost a lot of grit we
got a lot of visitors but we lost a lot
of grit I want grit so if North Korea
can somehow figure out a
way to entice travelers to come not
imprison and kill us but allow us to
kind of
navigate their very Bleak cold world I'm
into it and and I think a lot of other
people would be too a lot of other
people there's a novelty to going to
North Korea here's the good news here's
the good news there's a novelty to go to
North
Korea if I can fly to North Korea with a
bunch of people and we can stay in a
hotel and take photos in these vast
empty spaces that no one's allowed
in I'm in and I think a lot of other
people would be too because I know some
people that have a lot of money they're
all bored of going to the south of
France they're
bored a fun novelty trip to North
Korea could be [__] amazing getting
married in North Korea proposing in to
your wife in front of this big fountain
with a bunch of guards with guns and
that's the wedding
photo proposing in North Korea LOL how
the world has
changed they can do it they can do it
you don't have to disneyfy it you can
you can just lean in to the cold
creepy you know industrial thing that
they have I I I think a lot of people
would end up into it it would kind of
end up into it it's this country it's
run by this one family that's kind of
feuding all the time and it's it's total
absolute fascism like they will you will
be
disappeared so as long as I'm not afraid
of that I I like empty spaces I like
places that are not crowded and that all
is North Korea to be honest Florida at
Spring break not for me North Korea I
love it I love I love it just the the
sound of a fork and knife hitting a
plate and hear and nothing
else the one thing they've done is
they've created a space for
reflection and I think that's what North
Korea should kind of lean into we've
created a space for reflection where you
know all these people go to these
Spas they go to these Spas for what for
quiet can you get more quiet than North
Korea that you know this could be a new
modern spa for people that want to
reflect and North Korea will say if if
any of our residents leave their
buildings we kill them in the street you
will never hear anything we are the
quietest place you want to reflect white
lady from Santa Barbara come to North
Korea it will be quiet no one will
bother you no one will B we promise you
no one will B you will hear nothing you
will hear absolutely nothing you'll be
able to luxuriate whatever that the
version of that is but you'll be able to
walk around our completely empty cities
it's your city now it is a completely
empty City it'll just be the military
Hunter and you and if you can take a
girls trip where you are it is a
completely empty City it's a completely
empty City and it's just you and there's
no lines you know the V vacations are
it's nightmare lines did you book the
thing did you book The Boat did you book
the thing
picture is North Korea a continent no
but it's a country picture an entire
country that has been cleansed for
you the people are on their best
behavior there they're on their best
behavior they are not going to be a
problem they're not going to be they are
really they are just there to fade into
the background and to let you enjoy the
country it's kind of the perfect country
to travel to and I bet there's pretty
Google North Korea pretty things are
there pretty nice things there see the
mountains are there mountains I bet it
has Beauty I bet there's
Beauty it's the statues of him and his
dad yeah but by the way what a great
it's a great photo op but do you see
these empty cities are selling me yeah
they are selling it for me the at
totally empty
cities totally abandoned empty cities
where people are afraid to go because
they will be captured by the military
Hunter is a nice
vacation that is a nice vacation and
Americans will not ask where everyone is
this is how selfish we are we will be
the only group other people will go
where are all the people not us not us
let us in let us in I know you don't
want to because we're like whatever
about to go to nuclear war let the
people in we will not comment on what
you do Americans do not care when we go
on a vacation you could be doing a
genocide 15 minutes down the road if it
is not in front of us at our Resort we
don't care we do not care in fact we
will not care if the waiter from
yesterday
uh was macheted on the way in and they
said that to us they go yeah well I know
you like the waiter it's just so sad you
know him and his family were hacked up
by Rebel forces last night we go that's
terrible that's terrible so let me ask
you can we do breakfast on the beach
could you bring the chairs down is that
too much of An Inconvenient we don't
care we don't care you're you're not
letting an Americans that's that's a bad
MO you want to let in you want to let in
a group of people that doesn't give a
[__] what you're doing to your own
people and there's nobody that will play
along better than the United States
there's no Travelers you would want more
than fat American Travelers who are more
than willing to spend their money and
they will not care what you do to your
PE in fact they will come home and say
we should do that to people here they
will appreciate it they will app this
people talk about the Singapore caning
in this country only positive I've never
heard one person to say anything
negative about the caning in Singapore
everybody that has heard of the caning
or has seen the caning it is all
positive Americans will they'll go to
North Korea and go I like what they do
over there I'm telling they will come
back they will sit in a Denny's and they
will tell their friends you know people
say a lot about that government but it's
nice and quiet and everybody Minds their
business over there that's what you want
you want you don't want meddling
Europeans that blathering about human
rights or something you want Americans
to come in and enjoy your empty cities
and and speak highly of how you torture
your own people that's what you want and
that's what we'll do that's what we'll
do we will go to your dictatorship we
will we will thank you we will take
pictures in your in your vast uh open
spaces and we will come back and go you
know what they got a few things figured
out over there hello fresh you get free
breakfast for life is this true I can't
even imagine this how generous there
being as a company to my listeners
generosity is not going at a style at
hellofresh the thing about hellofresh is
nobody wants these Frozen things anymore
everybody wants fresh food you cook it
it's quick everything's right there for
you you don't have to go to the grocery
store everybody's sick and coughing and
touching each other touching the food
hello fresh you get fresh 15minute
recipes you make take them you're on a
date come on over make the food let's
make the taco here everyone's happy with
fresh food that can be cooked very
quickly I'm telling you this is the way
of the future it's actually the way of
the now they're also throwing in free
breakfast for Life they're they're
throwing in food for breakfast you don't
have to pay for it and it's such an
important
meal go to hellofresh.com I'm telling
you right now don't wait here don't
wait hellofresh is is giving
you I mean is this crazy free breakfast
for the rest of your
life if you if you keep the hellofresh
subscription you go to hellofresh.com
timd free and use the code timd free for
free breakfast for
Life One breakfast item per box while
subscription is active that's a free
breakfast For
Life do you
understand people go oh there's no such
thing as a free lunch guess what there
is a such thing there is such a thing as
a free breakfast from hellofresh from
the good people at hell because the name
is not a lie a lot of these uh companies
their name is a fib but this one is
hello
fresh because it's fresh from the
farm and it goes to your house and you
cook it you put it in the pan put it in
the
pot put it in the oven set it and forget
it look at a fresh meal from me and my
family my kids are eating fresh food and
they're not Gilbert goons because
they're eating fresh food delivered to
me for
free breakfast is free at hello fresh
breakfast is free at hello fresh
breakfast is free at hello
fresh don't arm your children with guns
arm them with a breakfast from
hellofresh hellofresh.com timd free
hellofresh.com timd free Santa baby give
me a manscaped lawn mower to shave my
genitals code is Tim D here we all love
manscape everybody uses it everybody
needs it it trims your PR private
sensitive areas Santa Baby I need a
trimmer for my balls that's
right go to manscape.com Santa Baby and
use the code Tim D T M
D Santa Baby I want to shave my pubic
hair without nicking my sha
balls go to manscape.com
it's it's amazing I'm telling you right
now look at this
is your boxer game weak take care of the
chestnuts with manscape boxers
2.0 wow they got their signature Jewel
pouch to keep your balls calm cool and
collected nose trimmers the shears Nails
nose they they're really trying to groom
you here they're expanding it's not just
the ball trimmer but they have it but
they're going for the nose hair the the
the you know the
nails they're going to take you and make
you a better person a more presentable
human being get 20% off and free
shipping with the code timd manscape.com
that's 20% off with free shipping at
manscape.com and use the code timd say
ho ho ho to a well-groomed mistletoe
with manscaped Southwest Airlines has
debuted their customer of size program
where if you are a fatty Bon batty you
can get an extra seat on one of their
planes now obviously the people who
travel Southwest are uh you know there's
no first class they are getting a good
deal but now there is a customer of size
policy meaning if you are a fatty Bo
batty you can go and demand an extra
seat at no charge from the people at
Southwest which is interesting right
because the way that they make money is
by selling their seats and if you are
fat now you can demand that they lose
money on a seat if you're girth hangs
into that seat you can demand it you can
demand it of them and they are offering
it they want to win the business of the
fats Southwest is coming out and going
many of the people that take our planes
are morbidly obese we need to keep
winning them
over the armrest is the definitive gauge
for a customer of
size it serves as the boundary between
SE if you're unable to lower both
armrests and or encroach upon any
portion of a seat next to you you need a
second
seat you need a second
seat what can I expect during boarding
if I'm a customer of
size
if if you have an extra seat if you have
an extra seat boarding document you need
a boarding document like North
Korea if you have an extra seat boarding
document you can choose to pre-board to
select seats that best meet your needs
you can also choose to board with your
original boarding group and position
once on board if necessary please
request a seat belt extension for our
flight
attendance can you ensure no one takes
the seat beside me if I've secured a
second seat unfortunately no we
encourage you to pre-board to locate
adequate seating and place the seat
Reserve document in the adjacent
seat our ground operations and inflight
employees communicate about customers
needs and if you need seating assistance
you should so they're going to give you
a they get you get on a plane they go
hey Piglet and they give you a thing
that a seat
reserved you go on the plane you're
sitting in the seat you're a fatty batti
some old hippie granola granny who's
visiting her son in Tulsa gets on the
Southwest flight sits next to
you appar you know obviously the seat
Reserve thing you got to keep telling
everyone who gets on a plane that you're
a fat [__] when they go the seats
Reserve go yeah and then eventually
people around you gonna go who's the
reserve for because eventually
everybody's going to be on the plane and
then that's when think of how
humiliating this is that's when okay cuz
apparently you've been sucking your gut
in the whole time that's when you take
the seat Reserve side you lift the
armrest and then you breathe out and you
let your gut then travel into the next
seat and then everybody goes oh that's
what it was
for what a humiliating
process what a humiliating process for
the Southwest customer of
size you have to get on the plane and
put a little piece of paper that says hi
I'm a fat [__] next to you the seat is
reserved and now everybody around you is
going to be like who is it reserved
for
but and then everybody will just
eventually assume they're like oh the
guy's he's
fat he's fat he gets the extra seat for
free he gets the extra seat for free
soon it will be a
row soon it will be a row because two
seats for a lot of people on airplanes
two seats are not
enough no be be honest they need a row
there will be a point when there are 13
people on a plane going from New York to
Phoenix and they all pay $8,000 for a
ticket or the government will start
subsidizing the airlines are going to go
to the government and go we're putting
fat people we're losing money and the
government's going to have to give the
airlines money the airlines are going to
go the people are too fat our profit
models getting all [__] up because
people are too fat to be in the seats
and the government's going to have a
choice they can stop poisoning the food
they could stop
allowing corporations to poison all the
food but they're not going to do that so
they're just going to shut the airlines
up they're gonna go here take a little
bit here's a little money because now
you're losing 30% of your seats you'll
get to a Southwest you'll eventually
walk onto a Southwest flight and
there'll be one seat in every row that
has that thing yeah yeah that says uh
this is
reserved for what my gut my gunt it's
reserved for my gun and then I just love
the idea of like you're on the runway
the boarding door has now been closed
and you're just sitting there and you're
like all right and you pick that up what
see what would be really funny is if you
put your food
there if right like if you put a bag of
McDonald's on on the seat on top of that
Reserve thing you put a bag of
McDonald's on the seat and then just
open it and then just you have your so
you've let your
gunt it's reserved for my gunt do you
not want my gunt to
breathe I don't know what's going on I'm
worried about the children I'm worried
about the what we're creating in this
country I'm truly worried about this I
hope there's Justice for this kid in
Arizona I hope that you know North Korea
figures out that the only people that
are going to truly appreciate your
dictatorship are Americans the only
people that are going to let you commit
human rights abuses while they Splash
around a quiet pool are Americans you
you need
us you need we need to come together on
this we will watch you publicly execute
people and we won't say a word just put
a waffle machine in the lobby we will w
we do not care I'm telling you we will
say only positive things about your
criminal justice system your military
Justice whatever it is we are on the
road Tim Dillan comedy.com we are on and
Taylor Loren by the way not going to her
Christmas for the fourth time in a ro
because of Co by the way starting to
like her starting to kind of like tayl
the Rens obviously she's blocked me on
Twitter and you know we don't see the
eye we don't see eye to eye but I got to
be honest with you starting to like Taya
Loren now because she literally go back
to my Google image thing go back to
Google there's so many photos of me that
I hate how why are they out there which
ones I don't
know anyway can I get the photos I hate
removed I had no atish be
on uh Tim comedy.com
folks BR at California this weekend
Columbus Ohio Bethlehem Pennsylvania
Washington DC Northfield Ohio San
Antonio Dallas Atlanta St Louis
Indianapolis Boston Boston another
Boston Connecticut Foxwood Chicago
Chicago Dania Beach India California out
there in Palm Springs Palm Desert
Phoenix Phoenix Atlantic
City a bunch of other casinos and stuff
too being announced
um you know I just I I I want to say
it's year end it's year end it's year
end it's the end of the year the year is
ending
and we're heading into a new year and
it's been a volatile year uh in the
world but you know what I I believe I
believe
that to
2024 we all expect it to be crazy and it
probably will
be but maybe for in in some
way wouldn't it be amazing if 2024 was
like boring wouldn't it be great
wouldn't it be lovely wouldn't it be
ideal what if Trump and Biden just both
die what if they both die and what if we
have the most boring it's DeSantis and
Nome what if we all move to North Korea
what a you know we keep anticipating
2024 with Dread but maybe it's actually
not going to be that bad maybe there
will be Justice for the Gilbert goons
maybe we find out the gilber Coons
didn't even do it we
won't but you know maybe
maybe maybe the Mormons uh save the
day maybe they stop ruining everything
with
Marriotts right yeah maybe my building
in New York City allows me to put a pool
on the
roof which I've been asking to do stop
with the engineers enough enough with
that crap maybe good things will
happen let's be positive let's you know
we spend a lot of time on this show
being negative because that's where the
news is but maybe the good things will H
maybe we will maybe Trump gets elected
and maybe people are actually okay with
it this time maybe it's just old hat and
there's no protests and no riots and no
one's you know what I
mean maybe Jeffrey Epstein comes back
and goes I've I'm not dead I was just
taking a break but I'm back and
everything's fine I don't know I don't
know how it how it
all but I'll tell you if you if you if
here's what I will tell you if you have
a positive attitude it means nothing and
I I want I I I I want to just end on
that note really if you wake up every
day and have a really good attitude and
and and and you have and you see the
world through a lens of positiv it means
it's it's utterly means nothing at
all so with that and and I'm not saying
don't do it but it has no bearing or you
know it just doesn't it just doesn't it
has no effect on the on the larger
issues you know what I
mean can Steve win make Gaza Sparkle
again can he make it
nice in 2024 will we not see Steve win
in
Gaza what if the 30 people that Israel
didn't over there all become Blackjack
dealers something's going to happen over
there that's good that's positive
something Good's gonna happen somewhere
I know it we might look back on
this and when you're on a roller coaster
in
Gaza and it's it's uh you know
it's it's a little
tasteless but you're on a roller coaster
and you know you're doing a bungee
jump and you're at the new Steve win
property in
Gaza the Anor Gaza and you're there and
you're going you
know
hey let's just enjoy what we got here I
know it you know it wasn't great because
that's what it's going to be in like 20
30 years you're going to be the Four
Seasons Gaza and you're going to go
oh it feels weird you're gonna this kind
of feels weird and you're gonna roll
over and you get a knock on your door
and the person's gonna hand you you know
the
uh like a nice eggs benedict with lavash
and to they're gonna find a way to do it
the way they do you know it's a little
hummus laa you know with the eggs and
we're gonna go and they're you're gonna
hi hi thank you so much are you like
originally from here and they're gonna
go yes and you're gonna go right you're
G to and how long have you lived and
your husband's gonna go honey honey no
no no
honey and then someone's gonna go I've
lost my family I was killed in the war
and you're gonna oh my God I'm oh no
that's so sad that's
horrible I'm sorry but we had two orange
juices